i've encountered you uh several times in
the past and i always go out of my way
to tell you how
i'm a big fan of yours we all are in my
family because you're such a funny
performer
you're a hilarious performer and i feel
a little bad because um
normally if you were on my show i would
provide
some kind of gift because that's what we
try to do on these talk shows
you know and today it's just a zoom call
and nothing no mug you get nothing
you get nothing well you know i you know
your show
is one of the shows where i really i
don't come for the mug
i want to be with you and i and i love
andy and
i'm such big fans of your of you guys
you know
when you talk about um having watched
new girl now with your kids and yeah and
and sort of discovering it and you've
said some very flattering things to me
um it's it's it's very uncomfortable for
me to hear because i remember
going on your show for the first time
and being like i don't know how to do
this show
these are two of the funniest human
beings on earth
and you know i think our instinct when
you're around people that you know are
just hands down funnier you that is just
to be quiet
well you i remember you being very
delightful and very funny
um i remember you uh complaining a bit
about the gifts
i'm curious about something who of the
talk show hosts who has the best swag
when you go visit well so
great question um
colbert for sure um yeah now colbert
like you don't want to schlep to new
york to do a talk show right um
but colbert you sort of do because you
you know what you're going to receive
when you get to your dressing room yes
actually i should let me take that back
you don't know what you're going to
receive you just know that it's going to
be
great i'll say this i'll say this about
steven's show this is my experience
um the last time i went on that show and
i walked into my
room i thought that i had won a game
show
there was uh there was electronics
there was a fur coat uh floor length
um just incredible stuff and i got very
self-conscious because i realized when
people come on our show
there's a mug that i i don't even think
it's a mug for our show
i think it's a mug from alf from the
like 1980s
and then uh we give them some popcorn
some like government-issued popcorn
so i felt horrible because they really
go all out my cap's off to those people
it feels like you're being re-gifted
things that stephen colbert
received
and you and you say to yourself man
stephen's got some knife
what we do at our show is i uh
we hoard stuff that we get from steven's
show that other people haven't used
and we hang on to it and mostly food so
it's food that we're giving away that's
from colbert's
guest room and it's like four years old
but
yeah but it's also like a beautiful
nantucket chocolate
i know it's not fair it's not fair and
uh
you know once again uh that man that man
i loathe him
um but he knows that that's another
[Laughter]
reason